hi I'm your team front and center for
development research university of
bondage on the front process is not over
actually the food security and nutrition
security Parliament of supporters are
increasing that needs to be hurt being
addressed by the redesign initiative of
the world economic forum thing it is
being now it needs to move on to the
g-train hair we need to take action and
the top agenda item should be to bring
more peace and quiet into the word for
Martha's the volatility in food prices
hurts people and under my skills it
needs to be addressed with a shared
reserve an emergency reserve and
morphing program and the virtual wizard
that has a capacity to prevent the food
price spikes which kill people so food
security back high on the agenda that's
why such